hey everyone thanks for coming to my
talk today my name is adriel and and I'm
gonna talk a little bit today about an
R&D project that I've been involved with
in charge of that work and it's it's
dealt a lot with you know building an
application in a CDF and I'm gonna talk
about some of the lessons that I've
learned working on that project just a
brief outline I'm gonna talk a little
bit about my company and what we do and
I think that that's sort of helpful to
frame the discussion and what I'm gonna
what's going to follow that I'm going to
talk a little bit about technology in
the oil and gas industry and then I'm
going to formally introduce our Rd
project called Alex and then I'm going
to talk through some of the the things
that I've learned with application
development and the Wolfram language and
then finally I'll just have a couple
quick remarks about Wolfram language
versus traditional languages and things
like that so about me
my background is in chemical engineering
and and I only say that to sort of
preface the rest of this presentation
I'm sure there's a lot of people out in
the audience right now that are you know
probably a lot better than me at some of
this stuff and and but really my goal
here is just to say you know some of the
things that I've learned over the last
year and a half working on this and I
think some of them are really good and
they'll be really useful for a lot of
people out there I've got five years of
experience and working in in oil and gas
now and I'm a my around my first year
halfway through my first year I got
introduced to Mathematica by a colleague
and and I really challenged myself I
could see right away the the value then
what you could do with it and I
challenged myself to basically learn as
much as I possibly could about it and
the way I did that is is I just I forced
myself not to open up Excel and open up
all those other things and I made myself
do everything with Mathematica and it
was you know a little bit of a learning
curve at first but it's really paid off
a lot now I use it I use it for
everything so just quick company
overview my company assured flow
solutions we focus on specialty
engineering and consulting in the
upstream oil and gas section the
specialty that we fall under is what's
called flow assurance and basically what
flow assurance is is we attempt to
that you have flow of hydrocarbons from
the reservoir to your topsides
most of our work is off so our offshore
so we're dealing a lot with subsea
pipelines primarily and and there's a
you know there's a lot of issues that
you can run into that people wouldn't
really think about a lot of those are
just pure sort of hydraulics you know
how do you how do you produce from a
well that's 20,000 feet below the ocean
in 8,000 feet of water do you have the
reservoir pressure that you need to
produce that kind of well there's a lot
of issues we deal with that have to do
with two-phase and three phase flow so
sometimes when you're when you're
producing from a reservoir you've got
you've got water you've got oil you've
got gas and it's all flowing in the same
pipeline and that creates a lot of
operational issues that people weren't
really aware of some of the other things
we focus on are some production
chemistry type issues related directly
to the oil so this is a picture of
what's called a hydrate and hydrated it
looks very similar to ice and it sort of
is in some ways but it's basically it
can form when you've got methane and
water present in your pipeline the real
the real special thing about it is that
it forms under high pressures and low
temperatures which is the exact
environment that you have in an offshore
pipeline just for for reference some of
the the ocean bed floor and the Gulf of
Mexico is around 36 to 40 degrees
Fahrenheit so it's really really cold
down there it's above freezing but it's
really cold and the hydrates they can
form the special thing about them is
that they form above freezing
temperatures you know they're very
pressure dependent so if one of these
forms and it blocks your pipeline then
you've got a major problem not only a
safety concern but you've also got loss
in production which is million dollar
million dollars per day so this is a
this is an example of a of an oil that's
got a lot of paraffin content in it and
that paraffin when it's exposed to a
cold pipeline it can it can deposit on
the inner inner wall of the pipe and
over time as it builds up it caused a
lot of issues you can see it almost to
the point where it's blocking the
pipeline right there and then this is
asphaltenes which can are another
characteristic of oils and sometimes
they can precipitate out under the right
conditions and when they do they just
form there's no way to dissolve them or
anything like that they just they form
and they can it can accumulate in BOC
your pipeline so we got we've got four
locations two in Houston one Adel
someone in Denver and we're sort of
really spread out we only have 20 people
in the company so for four locations
it's pretty stress really thin we just
opened up a new production chemistry lab
it opened last January and and the focus
there was we've primarily done
engineering it's halting work before
with a production chemistry lab we were
able to do some of the fluid testing
that we need to do on these oil samples
ourselves and basically be a third party
verification for some of that stuff and
a couple slightly with the engineering
work when you've got models that you're
running simulations they they require
parameters that you get from running
these kinds of analysis on the fluid
samples themselves so so a couple very
tightly with with it and it was sort of
something we were aiming to you know
increase as far as coupling even more in
the future so okay so in technology in
oil gas it really comes down to one
thing and that's better drilling when
you're talking about spending tens of
millions it's not 100 million dollars to
drill well especially offshore anything
that you can do to increase that process
make it more efficient it's gonna is
gonna equate to a lot of money so the
downside of that is that we're generally
late to the game as far as you know
conventional technology things related
to computers and you know and those
types of things and and so the real
thing I want to point out is that Excel
is still very dominant everyone uses
Excel if you get something from from
clients it's Excel and if you send
something it's Excel technology at my
company so we're where we use a lot of
very expensive simulation software to
sort of run our models and that's sort
of the base of it but we're no different
from anyone else in the industry a lot
of our stuff used to be Excel it used to
be you know one-off executables many
used to be you know it was just sort of
scattered everywhere like I said I
personally used the Wolfram language for
80% of my work and I've been trying to
get that to December to know that number
to grow you know spread awareness and
what my colleagues and things like that
but really about a year and a half ago
we realized that we needed something
better we needed some way that we could
manage all these internal processes that
we have and workflows and calculations
and so we decided to make something
that would they would handle that so so
like I said we needed something you know
that would handle these these
spreadsheets you know one-off
executables and even just you know VBA
macros and then we've got even just
company knowledge there's there's things
that there's people to have a lot of
experience and there's things that are
in their head and unless you go and talk
to them there's no way to get it out and
so we wanted to try to capture that as
well in this so before we started we had
this naming challenge for this R&D tool
that we wanted to build and the winner
was someone who submitted the name Alex
and it was named after the Library of
Alexandria which was the largest and
most significant library the ancient
world and it was only about two weeks
after that someone pointed out that that
library actually burned down so we're
hoping not to have the same fate with
our Alex so just really quick let me
kind of formally and show you Alex it's
it's developed in Mathematica by me and
it's distributed to my colleagues via an
enterprise CDF currently we have 37
unique utilities in it and those are
sort of accommodation of calculations
workflows you know processes all types
of things basically we just wanted a
one-stop shop for anything R&D related
that we had I can open it really quickly
like I said it runs in a CDF and over on
this side we've kind of got your main
utility panel and each one of these are
unique over here on the left is is where
you've got a list of all the available
utilities and you can do some nice
searching features if you need to search
for a particular thing and it'll sort of
filter the list so that's that's sort of
what it looks like here's that here's a
better way to sort of look at some of
the unique utilities that are available
in it and these are just some of them
not all of them just to give you a quick
highlight
so so like I said it leverages the power
of the enterprise CDF and that allows us
to have arbitrary input fields and we
can import file types of any of any type
which is really nice the searchable
field is also really nice you know
there's lots of times where you're not
quite sure what utility you need for the
job and if you put in a few keywords
I've tried to make it so that it's easy
to find that I've also added support for
250 oil and gas units that we have I
know there's unit conversion built in
the Wolfram language but I wanted
something that that didn't require an
internet connection and something that
we could easily build into the
functional programming so that's that's
kind of what you know these will these
will look like just one really basic
example and the thing that's nice about
how it's built is that I can run this in
Mathematica and I don't have to you know
run it in a CDF the way that my like my
colleagues do so this is a really simple
utility but we use it quite often to
generate a hydrate curve which of those
those things I mentioned earlier and
this basically shows us you know as far
as what is your temperature and your
pipeline and what's your pressure and if
you're to the left of this curve you're
at a you're at a pretty big risk for
forming hydrate in your mind and
blocking it and if you're to the right
you're sort of okay and we can add you
know inhibitor which they'll inject a
lot of chemicals into the pipeline to
help avoid some of these these
operational issues and and you can see
the effect of adding methanol basically
shifts that curve to the left and so you
you now have a whole you can go a lot
lower in your temperature and still not
have as many you're still not have that
operational risk this is a little bit
more exam answer example some of the
pipelines that we looked at are really
highly engineered pipelines and you know
it's not it's not a simple steel pipe
that they're just laying on the ground
there's there's a lot of engineering
that goes into the insulation of them
when you're dealing with temperatures
that are you know a few degrees above
freezing you need to have as much
insulation as you can and so there's a
lot of different wall layers in some of
these pipes and so we built this utility
and it uses nd solve and we can specify
the wall materials you know the thermal
properties of it and then if we
calculate it we can basically simulate
as soon as I shut in a pipeline you know
how long do I have and a cool down time
until I hit some designated temperature
and that's going to be the temperature
which you know I'm not
for for some operational issues normally
hydrates but the nice thing is because
it's you know it's an interpolating
function I can also look at these
results not just in the time domain but
I can also look at I can look them out
in the spatial domain and sort of the
radial distance and the pipeline so how
do we decide to develop Alex we had a
couple options we had Excel Visual
Studio we had Mathematica and
you know I'm obviously a huge supporter
of Mathematica but at the end of the day
what it really came down to was that we
needed something that we could dealt
very fast like we're not we're not in
the R&D business we're in the you know
clients and project business and
something so we needed needed something
that worked it was accurate and and we
could build it really quickly and so and
develop 37 different utilities inside of
Visual Basic is not something that's
gonna take the amount of time that we
needed it to or though it doesn't matter
of time that we had so so the code
structure is so that the rest of the
slides that I just want to go through
really kind of briefly on each one how
you know I've approached a certain issue
related to application development with
the Wolfram language and and just to
give you guys an idea of how it's all
set up so alex is contained in a package
that's really nice for naming
conventions it makes it really easy to
isolate your code and using the
different you know the colon key or
whatever you can isolate it and grab a
particular variable from a certain
context I also like the package editor
basically just because it allows me to
collapse these different sections and I
can organize it really nicely I can I
can have you know an image individual
module and then everything related to
that and and isolate out the methods
from the UI and things like that and the
other thing that's nice is when you have
it in a package as opposed to see yes
you can protect that and you can encode
it and and that way your intellectual
property safe so the inside sender the
UI really quick the whole so the whole
thing is obviously in the CDF on the top
we've got a docked cell and then the
remainder of the the notebook runs is
all wrapped around a dynamic module
wrapped inside of a dynamic module and
then each individual utility
has its own dynamic module and then
inside of that is a pain because a lot
of these extend beyond the on the screen
and we wanted something that we could
scroll through and then over here that
search will feel that I mentioned before
and then just a pain here with a with a
column of buttons in each one if you
click it you know it sets the the
appropriate utility that you want to
view so all of us have written
mathematical code we know that there's
no compiling and that's that's what's
great about it I did want to have
something that would allow me to build
Aleks and what it basically does is I
wrote this function that compiles to
compile Aleks and it and it takes the
file as a package and it moves it over
to the appropriate user base directory
for Mathematica and for C or for the CDF
player and in the process it encodes it
so that it's it's protected and you
can't can't view it in raw text form and
what it also will do is update a version
number that that I cannot maintain
separate from the utility and then if I
want I can it has an option that it will
accept its own version number so if I
want to increment the next version
number I can do that manually so version
control it's you know it's critical for
any successful software project and Alex
because it's in a package form and it's
a text form it's very easy to maintain
it using it and because it's raw text
you can do diffs on the different
versions really easily so it's it's nice
as opposed to using a notebook which has
a lot of cells and a different a lot of
additional text if you actually looked
inside of it and and that makes it a
little bit more difficult for the
version control updates when I first
arted working on Alex we was updates
sometimes twice a week and I always
wanted to make sure that people had an
easy way to get the latest version so I
have all the files sort of associated
with Alex in one central spot and then I
wrote this little executable here and
that'll copy those files to the the
appropriate spot on their computer
system under there under that same user
user base directory in that way when the
when the Alex launches it knows exactly
where to go to look for those for those
files and it can load them in really
easily
so this is something I I've only
recently started doing actually and I
knew that Wolfram had automated testing
but I hadn't had a chance to really look
at it yet and and once I did I was I was
really impressed I mean just just like
anything else with real form it's it's
really easy to test your functions and
you can write you know a few few lines
to change some variables and account for
different things that the user might do
and then you can run a test and set that
up as a test and then when you run it
you'll easily see if you if you broken
anything with the past version stuff
like that which which I tend to do so
it's nice to have this bug reporting so
right away when I first built this I
built in the upper right corner this
little button report bug and it uses the
the send mail function to basically send
me send me a email and with that email
I'll get information about all the
variables and that utility what current
utility they're using and it also sent
me you can take a front-end screen shot
using Mathematica code and it'll send me
a screenshot of that and lots of times I
can see you know what are the red boxes
or something you can if something's not
working right but you really need some
some way to do that because Wolfram's
really good about not letting their
program crash so you don't necessarily
know that it just it just broke you just
know that something's not really working
right and so I needed some way to report
that and let people know and and now I
probably get one of these every every
two to three weeks so so there's been
improvement debugging I know there are
ways of debugging inside of the package
inside of the notebook interface and
other other areas but I tend to just do
it directly in Mathematica I like to be
able to do exactly whatever my colleague
that broke something whatever they were
doing I like to repeat those steps in
here and then I'll generally just look
at you know the exact variables and and
I can look at you know just the raw data
and things like that and I can kind of
figure out what's going on like that
that's that's how I'll generally
approach it just a couple extras one of
the big things that we wanted was an
easy way to get data out of the utility
so we used to when I originally wrote
this
we had an export function and what it
would do is let someone save the file
somewhere and then an excel file a CSV
file and you kind of file and then you
know it
export that data and then when they
needed it they would have to go open
that data and I was always really
interested in the idea of the copy to
clipboard but if you've ever used it in
Mathematica and you and you actually
copy the data it's really nice for
pasting in between notebooks
but it's not really nice if you want to
paste it to excel so so I wrote my own
my own data and and then when I paste
that it looks a little weird right here
but if you were to paste that in Excel
to be tab-separated and and everything
would look really nice so that's that's
built into all the utilities and you can
just export all that data really easily
and you'll have to do that that second
and third step the save load every every
utility that's in there right now has
has an option to save the current
configuration and I wanted something
that was really generic to do that and
so I basically wrote this this little
code right here and it'll take the name
whatever the utility is and then all my
variables associated with that it'll
write them as an association to a file
with the string as the variable and then
the value and then similarly when I load
that back in I could take those those
same strings and just convert them into
into symbols and then set the values and
it works really nicely and I don't ever
have to manually go through and set
which variables I want to save it just
it's handled for each utility okay
finally
so advantages of Wolfram language for
application development algorithms can
be developed very quickly and you
generally require a lot less code which
which I'm sure all of you are aware of
but when it comes to things like R&D
projects it's really nice to have and
its really nice to do it that way
limitations for me as far as what I saw
the application development there were
some strong limitations and the UI
capabilities I don't think you're ever
going to be able to develop a
professional you know looking desktop
application you know there's just some
limits in the in the way the notebook is
set up but I mean I think you can get to
something that looks pretty nice and
especially if it's for quick you know
internal development I think it'll
probably meet any requirements that you
have
so conclusion so future Daleks we've got
a growing list of utilities dad right
now probably you know we're at 37 I
think I'll probably easily get up to 50
we're dealing a lot more with the lab
now with our lab and sort of coupling
the engineering work with the lab and
there's there's a lot of opportunities
there to expand further with that and
I've been really interested in the cloud
opportunities and learning specifically
about API functions his way to to call
those instead of running these things
through CDF so that all that might be in
the future
so Wolfram language obviously plays a
very vital role at AFS not just for me I
use it personally and every sort of work
function I do but also in the ability to
distribute these these CDF to my
colleagues which get used daily as well
and lastly you know they we're all aware
that Wolfram language can play a huge
role in the industry and sort of
preaching to the choir obviously but you
know I think it's all of our jobs to you
know just increase that awareness and
you know keep doing what we're doing
spreading the word because it's a really
powerful tool and that's it thank you
[Applause]